the former prime minister of Japan was
assassinated and it was because of his
connections to a very evil cult let me
explain
it's July 8 2022 at 11 30 a.m in Nara
Japan Shinzo Abe Japan's longest serving
former prime minister steps up on stage
and starts delivering a speech he's
surrounded by Security on all sides and
everyone is listening very intently to
his words the crowd was so captivated
that nobody notices that there's a man
slowly creeping up behind the former
prime minister nobody sees him not even
the security it's just a normal campaign
rally and that is when it happened
thank you
[Music]
shot what a homemade gun Abe falls to
the ground bleeding out but still
conscious and the crowd starts turning
chaotic some people rush to help Mr Abe
others tackle the shooter who doesn't
make an attempt to run away just two
minutes after the gunshots and the
suspect is dragged off into police
custody 11 36 am a helicopter is
requested to airlift him to a local
hospital for treatment but by the time
he arrives at the hospital he was
already going into cardiac arrest less
than six hours later Shinzo Abe is
pronounced dead with the killer in
custody 42 year old tetsuyu yamagami
made sure everyone knew Crystal Clear
why he did it he killed the former prime
minister because of one thing Shinzo
Abe's deep ties with the evil coat that
ruined his life the unification Church
[Music]
foreign
the world is falling into a recession
right now which means things are about
to get a lot worse however if you're
looking to start a business right now
this is actually a good thing Apple
Airbnb Microsoft Netflix Uber and a ton
more were all started during a recession
and one of the best businesses to start
right now is e-commerce you know Dr
squash with those funny bar soap ads
they make over a hundred million dollars
per year dude wipes who literally just
sells wipes is valued at 300 million
dollars while athletic greens they're
valued at over a billion dollars so if
you're going to start an e-commerce
brand or you have one already you're
gonna need super fast efficient and
affordable shipping especially around
the holiday season coming up that's why
you gotta check out shipstation today's
video sponsorship station is the easiest
most efficient and most affordable
shipping software out there that's
already helped over 130 000 e-commerce
Brands grow their company shipstation is
so good that 98 of companies that use
ship station for a year keep using it
for as long as they're in business with
shipstation you'll have access to the
best shipping carriers and highly
discounted rates are normally only
available to Giant companies it works
for more than 300 different platforms
including Amazon Etsy and more you can
ship anywhere in the world you can
automate every shipping test with just a
few clicks and you can even handle
orders right from your phone plus
shipstation is also available in the UK
Australia and Canada this holiday season
give yourself the gift of stress-free
holiday shipping by going to
shipstation.com for a 60-day free trial
that's too much of Cheaper easier
shipping completely free so go to
shiftstation.com with the link below
right now thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
long before the shooting tetsuya
yamagami had a plan for years his anger
and resentment towards the unification
Church brewed he hated the cult
he wasn't a member himself but the most
important person in his life was his
mother even now yamagami's mother has
been vocal about her support for the
church and not her son quote to her the
unification church is everything it is
life itself she thinks nothing about her
son end quote yamagami's uncle said see
68 years ago an excommunicated Minister
named son Moon had big news for the
people of South Korea he was Jesus's
appointed successor and he had been
handed down his mission by God to
encourage his followers to marry and
raise the ideal family basically his
goal was to uphold extreme conservatism
to fulfill these Godly duties Moon
organized Mass weddings he matched
thousands of couples together sometimes
he just randomly paired photographs of
people who had never met before and
decided they should be married it was
the start of a brand new religion that
quickly attracted more and more
followers a religion that eventually
blossomed into the unification Church in
the beginning the church was known for
its ultra-conservative values this
helped the religion expand overseas
during the Cold War when conservative
philosophies were spreading like
wildfire soon the unification Church
made its way to South Korea's next-door
neighbor Japan in the early 60s the
church's leader became very close
friends with a Japan Japanese man named
no bisque Kishi Japan's prime minister
and Shinzo Abe's grandfather ah yes it's
all coming together before he was even
born Shinzo Abe's family had deep ties
to the unification church with kishi's
help the unification Church started
quickly seeping into Japanese culture
and politics in 1968 the church got into
the political game by founding an
organization called The International
Federation of victory over communism the
organization joined forces with the
liberal Democratic party to fight
against communism and leftist Views and
that took the church's power and
influence to the next level
all of a sudden it wasn't just a church
but a church with political power soon
new Japanese members started joining it
wasn't long before the unification
church had millions of followers and
became became one of the biggest
religions in Japan young people in Japan
were attracted to the unification church
it was enticing as one former member
describes it quote you felt you were
part of something very Noble and very
wholesome end quote but as many members
would soon find out the church was after
one thing and one thing only money and
they were experts at extracting it out
of members
foreign
[Music]
a big part of the church's beliefs
centered around sins that people are
inherently sinful and that can land them
in a very bad place if they don't do
something about it quote they plant fear
in you saying that you are full of sin
and corrupted you will end up in hell
and your family will face a similar fate
end quote a former follower by the pen
name of fumiyaki Tada said
thankfully the unification church had
the solution to put its members back on
the path to Salvation money lots and
lots of money as much as they could get
their hands on the unification Church
liked to coax its members into quote
spiritual sales end quote offering
people Supernatural powers from God and
to cleanse them of their sins all for a
very Hefty price they usually Target
grieving elderly people who are
searching for hope
if the spiritual sales didn't work the
church demanded their followers gather
donations with an insanely High quota if
they couldn't come up with the cash they
were told to borrow money to contribute
to the church even forcing members to
give the church money against their will
since 1987 nearly 35 000 people have
taken the unification Church to court
claiming that the church had
collectively conned them out of about
863 million dollars over the years
and what did the church do with this
money what any Savvy cult leader would
do they let that money work for them
the unification Church invested that
money into a ton of assets that include
a conglomerate called tangyil group that
owns a variety of resorts a chemical
group a car parts company a defense
Corporation and a newspaper along with
stakes in the Washington Times newspaper
the New Yorker Hotel and the true World
Foods Seafood wholesaler plus a
ridiculous amount of real estate quote
it is a business based on religion end
quote said a professor at Busan
Presbyterian University quote on the
surface they are fighting over religious
principles but they are actually
fighting over money end quote
and all of this wealth was fueled by
donations from people like Shinzo Abe's
Killer's mother
the Killer's mother joined the church
over three decades ago she became one of
the church's most devoted members his
mother donated around 100 million yen to
the unification church that that's well
over 700 000 American dollars today with
the current conversion rate and the
yamagami family wasn't wealthy or
anything his mom mainly came up with the
money by selling real estate and by
giving away her dead husband's life
insurance policy the unification Church
drained her bank account and the
yamagami family went bankrupt putting
the killer tetsuya yamagami in a
devastating position
his dad had passed away his mother
didn't love him and had given all their
money away to this cult so their family
was left with nothing despite being
described as extremely smart and
hard-working the bankruptcy forced
tetsuya yamagami to abandon his plans to
attend college his life was a sham and
he blamed it all on the unification
Church his resentment and frustration
festered he felt powerless he wanted to
do something he had to do something
something big
the answer was as clear as day he needed
to kill the current leader of the
unification Church hak yahan Moon the
wife of the late Church founder but once
covet hit it threw a wrench in the plot
Japan shut down its borders so the
church leader stopped coming to Japan
it was basically impossible to get to
her but yamagami couldn't wait any
longer he had to act and that's when he
saw Shinzo Abe's video a video message
published in 2021 for the universal
peace Federation a group affiliated with
the church in the video Shinzo Abe
praised the church leader hakyahan Moon
gushing over how much he appreciated her
efforts in promoting traditional Family
Values it was the final straw an
accessible Target praising the church
that took everything away from yamagami
a politician with a lot of influence in
Japan telling the people how much he
loved the unification Church in his mind
the decision had already been made he
was going to assassinate Shinzo Abe not
for his controversial political career
but for his connection to the
unification church and the craziest part
of it all is that this senseless act of
violence actually might have
accomplished exactly what yamagami
wanted he got a lot of eyeballs looking
into the unification Church's hand in
Japanese politics
[Music]
when yamagami said he killed Abe because
of his association with the unification
Church the Japanese government started
taking a hard look at the cult a sketchy
Church conning members out of millions
is one thing but political connections
or even possibly manipulating the
government is another thing entirely so
the current Japanese government did an
internal investigation and quickly
discovered that almost half of Japan's
governing lawmakers had ties to the
unification Church half that's a
ridiculous amount of power for a South
Korean church to have in Japan's
government
some of these lawmakers just attended
church events but others were getting
support during elections making speeches
for the church or even accepting money
from the organization the infiltration
was stunning what started with the
assassination of the former prime
minister ended up unraveling into a
potential government corruption crisis
for Japan
a professor named Jeffrey Kingston put
it blatantly quote the church's
extensive and long-standing political
role has been kept obscure until the
assassination end quote
foreign
[Music]
's death things moved pretty quickly
tetsuya yamagami is detained and
undergoing psychiatric evaluation to see
if he was too crazy to be punished the
Japanese government decided to hold a
controversial State funeral for former
prime minister Shinzo Abe costing
billions of dollars the funeral of
Japan's former prime minister Shinzo Abe
has taken place amid tight security at a
Buddhist temple in Tokyo an event that
cost over 11 million dollars worth of
taxpayer money to fund thousands of
people took to the streets to mourn
Abe's death but just as many people were
outraged and protested the event saying
that the taxpayers shouldn't have to pay
for the extravagant funeral
[Applause]
one poll found that around 60 percent of
citizens were against the multi-billion
dollar funeral but the show went on
anyway as for the Japanese government
well they're doing their best to pick up
the pieces for Mio kishida the current
prime minister of Japan ended up
reshuffling his cabinet and ordering ldp
legislators to sever ties with the
church
he even announced a new program to help
former members of the church with things
like legal aid to try to get their
donations back he acknowledged the
churches quote many victims and quote
and said quote efforts to help them are
still insufficient end quote
perhaps the craziest part of the story
is that a lot of people actually
sympathize with this Assassin's story
almost 8 000 people have signed a
petition urging that yamagami receive a
reduced sentence sympathizers have sent
clothing food and comic books to him in
jail some have even donated money to
yamagami over seven thousand dollars in
Cold Hard Cash so far so as it turns out
yamagami's plan might have actually
worked better than he imagined
the unification church is a very evil
business but an even more Sinister
business you need to know about is
China's forced organ harvesting trade
where China forcibly harvests the organs
of political prisoners to sell them off
to rich people in the west why because
in the west patients have to wait for
organ donors to die of natural causes
which leads patients to have to wait
years for an organ China saw this Gap in
the marketplace and they pounced and
even though everyone should know this
stuff is happening we would get
demonetized immediately for talking
about these types of things on YouTube
publicly so we released it as a private
dock that's only available to members of
this channel members love it you can
watch this exclusive documentary and all
of the new ones we release every month
by clicking the join button below and
there's a refund policy too unlike most
YouTube memberships so scroll down and
click that join button now
[Music]
foreign